look live at the control tower there at
mccarran right now but they've already
been having a lot of issues at mccarran
over the weekend southwest airlines
canceled more than 1800 flights at
airports nationwide and those problems
are expected to stretch into this week
southwest is struggling to get its
operations back to normal today and more
flight cancellations hit mccarran this
afternoon now there are different
explanations of why this is all
happening hector mejia is tracking all
of that for us this afternoon he's live
at mccarran with the latest
hector
well it's already supposed to be a busy
travel day with today being a federal
holiday here at mccarran
34 southwest flights canceled for today
and that's part of 300 other flights
canceled across the country by the
airline that's according to flight aware
an aviation tracking website
on sunday alone southwest airlines
canceled more than 1 thousand u.s
flights that's almost 30 percent of the
airline's scheduled flights southwest
initially blamed air traffic control
issues then severe weather however other
airlines did not cancel nearly as many
flights marlene northup is traveling to
the phoenix area we had gone to
reno tahoe for a family wedding we were
supposed to fly out
sunday morning and when we got to the
airport the flight was canceled we're
looking forward to being home
and
putting this all behind us and getting
on with our lives the southwest airlines
pilot association blamed poor planning
by southwest there's talk about staff
shortages in a statement it said in part
quote our pilots are not participating
in any official or unofficial job
actions matthew hatha is not a southwest
passenger but had to deal with the
ripple effects he could not find a
flight to phoenix so he spent 15 hours
at mccarran airport until a rental car
became available feels like i'm homeless
almost in the sense i don't have a car
i don't have a you know
a place to stay
my own bed i slept on the floor upstairs
for about four hours
southwest encourages its passengers to
try the self-service rebooking option on
its website i reached out to the airline
today for a new statement we'll let you
know as soon as we get one reporting
from mccarran airport hector mejia live
local now